[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
Славське]
Ми проєктуємо і будуємо екологічні будинки.
Тобто мандруємо по світу, вивчаємо технології
і приїжджаємо, щоб спробувати втілити тут.
Ми писали листи до різних
екологічних організацій світу:
[Едуард Пастух
Архітектор]
до Бельгії, Франції,  Нідерландів, Німеччини.
Відгукнулися лише голандці.
[Ольга Суха
Архітекторка]
Нас запросили, сказали,
щоб приїжджали у гості. Чому б ні?
Ми поїхали в гості до голландців.
Вони такі відкриті люди, кажуть:
«Ми і до вас приїдемо, спробуємо, щось покажемо».
Спочатку була ідея просто
спробувати на частині стіни,
щоб зрозуміти, як трамбувати соломою,
працювати з глиною.
Потім ми зрозуміли, що це несерйозно
зробити лише шматок стіни,
і вийшла ціла хата.
Тут всюди солома: у підлозі, стінах, стелі і даху.
Такий собі солом'яний кокон.
Екобудівництво — це специфічна галузь,
яка потребує дуже ретельного
ставлення до деталей.
Наприклад, якщо в цьому будинку
неправильно пофарбувати стіни
не тою фарбою або ґрунтовку
взяти не ту, що треба,
то стіна перестане дихати.
Буде застій.
Через п'ять років вона може почати псуватися.
Ми починали будувати з дерева.
Реально шкода дерево...
Коли будуєш з дерева, то ти бачиш,
скільки гектарів лісу треба вирізати для цього.
Навіть тяжко назвати такі будинки екологічними.
Це Едік розповідає про технічні моменти.
А насправді для чого це все?
Завжди є якась магія архаїки,
природних речей.
Цю підлогу я робила своїми руками,
стіни також.
Ці всі фарби змішувала.
Наприклад, ця стіна створена
зі змішаного воску зі скипидаром,
лляним маслом і теракотовим барвником.
Це сакральний процес.
Підлога — це сажа з глиною,
вапном і скипидаром.
Це все на цій буржуйці варилося. Така магія.
Власне про міф архаїки:
вона вже віджила своє.
Наша ідея полягає на тому,
щоб модернізувати архаїку
і отримати її емоційну складову.
Водночас користуючись
благами сучасної цивілізації.
Тут планується будівництво по різних технологіях.
Там внизу будується будинок,
і він буде зроблений з костри коноплі.
На сьогодні це найцікавіший матеріал.
Дійсно екологійний, доступний.
Костра коноплі —  це залишки коноплі.
Є технічна конопля, вона височезна —
біля чотирьох метрів.
З якої теж споконвіку шили одяг.
Вона дуже багато використовувалася у побуті.
Усередині ми плануємо [облаштувати будинок]
конопляними тканинами.
Постіль — конопляна.
Окрім того, до нас приїжджали [гості] з Австралії.
Вони хочуть збудувати підземне житло.
Їм запропонували місце, як-от Гобітон.
Отакі підземні будинки.
У нас є дуже гарний південний ухил,
який ми можемо використати.
Тобто є така ідея.
Ми хочемо будувати подібне
і спробувати експлуатувати.
Дивитися, як вони себе поводять
і щоб люди, яким це цікаво,
могли пожити і доторкнутися.
Зрозуміти, чи їм підходить таке
та чи взагалі потрібно.
Тут приїжджають театральні групи,
тому ми хочемо створити таку атмосферу...
Щоб люди самі хотіли...
Щоб спонукати їх до творчості.
Тобто вони спілкуються...
Власне, на перетині різних дисциплін
створюються якісь геніальні речі.
Ми хочемо теж запрошувати різних кухарів,
пробувати різні...
— І місцеву кухню...
— ... смаки і їх поєднання.
Це отакий майданчик
для реалізації різних ідей.
Фантасмагорія, скажімо.
Хтось каже: «Я хочу спробувати таку кухню,
поекспериментувати».
Будь ласка — приїжджай, роби!
Людський ресурс є провідним
в екологічному будівництві.
Майстри, які тут копають ями, кладуть дахи,
пізніше виявляються неймовірними музикантами,
народними майстрами.
Ми тут довго шукали людину,
щоб у селі покрити стіну глиною.
пів Славського обходили,
а потім сусідка знизу прийшла і запропонувала.
У них існує канон: чоловік не може
обробляти стіни глиною...
Вони називають це болотом, говорять,
що стіни і болото — це жіноча робота.
Я й сама теж робила.
Таємниця в нас є одна.
Одна і дуже важлива:
треба просто поважати людей,
з якими ти працюєш.
Навіть робітника, який копає яму.
Це не найлегше, що може бути.
Для тебе це найдешевша робота,
найпростіша і найдієвіша.
Треба просто поважати кожного.
Поважати всіх інших людей,
з якими ти працюєш.
Цінувати те, що вони віддають тобі свій час
і для тебе це роблять.
Це найбільша таємниця.
Зверху, над ресторанчиком,
буде творча майстерня для художників.
Зараз у світі популярні резиденції.
Художник, письменник чи музикант
приїжджає сюди на місяць.
Він творить, і результат його діяльності презентується.
Людям має бути цікаво там втілюватися.
Вони мають бачити, що їх там почують,
що їхні ідеї можуть мати якесь продовження.
Так само у Хорватії.
Випадково купили оливковий сад на березі моря.
Він закинутий,
тобто там груди каміння.
Раніше весь острів Брач залило лавою.
Щоб добратися до землі, треба її очистити.
Вони її складали в гарні купи
і з того будували будинки, столи,
робили собі ліжка, чани для олії.
Такий собі культ каменю.
Зараз їм воно вже не так цікаво.
Коли ми приїжджаємо, то бачимо цю автентику
і нам хочеться цю ідею теж втілювати.
Так, різні кладки.
Суха кладка, тобто будинки будували без розчинів.
Тут ми теж стикалися з різними ситуаціями.
Люди виносили на двір дерев'яні столи і рубали.
Тим столам по триста років,
з одної плиниці.
За ним їли їхні прадіди.
Потім купують з ДСП, які хитаються.
Це дуже сумно...
Ми того не цінуємо і не бачимо.
— Тому що це таке якесь буденне.
— Буденне.
Так, вони собі ходять у звичайному одязі
і побачити не буденне в цьому буденному...
Коли є простір...
Магія створення чогось...
Оцей простір, то цікаво вплітати у нього свої мрії і бажання.
Власне, ти ходиш і
відчуваєш так, ніби людина...
Пливе, адже природа лишається недоторканою...
Вона менше торкає природу
і просто пропливає над усією красою.
Так народилися сходи.
І тепер легенди про них пишуть,
що це найдовші прямі сходи в Україні.
Кожен шукає у своєму житті якесь заняття,
яким він може займатися без грошей.
Він просто тим живе.
Якщо хтось знайшов таке заняття,
то стає щасливим.
Так, ми просто без цього себе не уявляємо.
Без будівництва, без мандрів і експериментів.
Китайці кажуть: «Знайдіть улюблену роботу
і ви не будете працювати жодного дня».
— Ми себе знайшли саме тут.
— Так.
Одне з місць, де ми себе знайшли.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Василь Гошовський]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Олексій Собчук]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Гапочка, Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]